le verte l'écologie et il le vert de
l'islam ça c'est la grosse question le
vert de l'islam est né à mahomet la
tradition veut que c'est une couleur qui
l'aimé beaucoup qu'il partait au combat
avec un étendard vert et un turban vert
cette tradition très fort j'ai assez tôt
après sa mort
mais assez rapidement cette couleur qui
était peut-être dynastique chez les
héritiers de mambé est devenue la
couleur qui fédérait toutes les
tendances de l'islam c'est devenu la
couleur religieuse de l'islam
au fil du temps ce n'a aucun rapport
avec le verre des écologistes qui lui
est assez banalement le vert de la
végétation
par extension le vert de la nature
pendant assez longtemps la nature ne se
définissait pas par rapport au monde
végétal la nature c'était l'eau l'air la
terre et le feu les quatre éléments
17 à l'époque romantique à la fin du
xviiie au début du 19e siècle que la
nature a fini par être assimilée au
monde végétal et la couleur du monde
végétal ou le verre est dominant est
devenue celle de l'idée de nature et des
défenseurs de la nature de
l'environnement la couleur de l'écologie
on
au moment